to Sudan now where the military has
attacked possessions of the paramilitary
rapid support forces in the capital
fighting between the rsf and the Army
has been spreading from the capital
Khartoum to other parts of the country
since it started in mid-april the United
Nations is warning the conflict could
tip the region into a humanitarian
catastrophe it estimates the violence
has forced at least 4 million people
from their homes let's bring in our
correspondent hibber Morgan she's
joining us live from cartoon Really
striking pictures of this attack Heber
what was the target
well we know that the Sudanese Army's
aircraft's targeted positions of the
paramilitary rapid support forces around
the vicinity of the general command of
the Army Headquarters now just to give
you an idea the general command of the
armies under the control of the army
itself but the areas around it are
dominated by the rapid support forces
since the start of the conflict in
mid-april and we understand from sources
in the army that the target of those
airstrikes were Fuel and ammunition
Depots around the vicinity of the
general command but that was not the
only airstrike launched today by the
Sudanese Army against positions of the
paramilitary rsf they were also drone
strikes in the eastern part of the
capital and there were also airstrikes
launched in the southern part of the
capital also around areas that are
dominated and bases that are belonging
to the paramilitary rapid support forces
as well as artillery strikes that were
launched from the city of umdurman
towards the northern part of the country
so Shillings airstrikes continue and
they will also aren't by the rsf and
most of them are landed on civilian
homes according to reports from
witnesses around the armored Corps
another military base so the fighting
continues the artillery shelling
continues and as is the airstrikes by
the Sudanese army with the hopes of
dislodging the paramilitary rapid
support forces from their positions in
the capital
all right Heather we're also hearing the
situation for civilians in South 34 is
just getting worse
we asked fighting between the Army and
the paramilitary rsf since uh August
11th of all August has led to a lot of
Civilian casualties now hundreds have
been reported killed and many others
have also been injured and we understand
from the aid organization Doctors
Without Borders that the only hospital
that was providing Medical Treatments to
those who've been injured as a result of
the artillery shelling landing on
civilian homes have now has now been
occupied by one of the wearing sites now
Doctors Without Borders did not state
which of the two wearing sites has
dominated or taken over the hospital but
it did say that the situation is getting
quite catastrophic that many people now
have no access to health facilities and
that many people continue to get injured
as a result of the artillery shellings
uh by both the rsf and the Sudanese Army
many people have been trying to make
their way out of there but then again
it's in South Darfur there are thousands
of people who have been displaced by 20
years of conflict even prior to this
we're starting many of them have nowhere
to go to and have nowhere to leave the
capital as the fighting continues and
the artillery shelling continues
thank you very much for that that is
Heather Morgan with the latest live in
cartoon